السعوديه تدشن اول رحله صعود الى الفضاء
ضمن برنامج المملكه الذي يحدث لتاهيل
كوادر السعوديه متمرسه لخوض رحلات فضائيه
طويله وقصيره المدى والمشاركه في التجارب
العلميه والابحاث الدوليه المتعلقه
بالفضاء راى فضاء سعوديه في مهمه
وبرناوي وعلي القرني وبرفقه اخرين
امريكيين هما جون شفنر وتاجي اختي
بعد خضوعهما لتدريبات مكثفه واختبارات
حاسمه كانت كفيله بترشيحهما لهذه الرحله
التي ستنطلق من ولايه فلوريدا الامريكيه
اكيد استاذ اصلا مهمتنا بالاساس هي مهمه
علميه فباذن الله سنقوم باجراء 14 تجربه
علميه بحثيه رائده يعني لاول مره في
التاريخ باذن الله هذه التجارب تعنى
بمجالات متعدده اولها هي ثلاث تجارب
توعويه تعليميه ستكون
لها علاقه بالتعاون مع الطلاب فهذه
التجارب كلها هدفها تحفيز الطلاب وتحفيز
الفضول لديهم في مجال الفضاء وباذن الله
سنقوم باجراء اربع تجارب علميه لها علاقه
بالخلايا المناعيه وهذه باذن الله حتكون
اول مره في التاريخ سنقوم بزراعه خلايا
مناعيه في بيئه الجاذبيه الصغرى بحيث انه
نزرع الخلايا ونضيف علاجات مختلفه عليها
ونشوف مدى استجابتها في بيئه الجاذبيه
الصوره وهذي البحث لاول مره يجرى في
التاريخ بدعم سمو سيدي حفظه الله
اذا مده المهمه اثني عشر يوما سيقوم رواد
الفضاء فيها باجراء اربع عشره تجربه علميه
تتعلق بالدماغ والدم وعلوم الخلايا اضافه
لتجارب الاستمطار في الجاذبيه الصغرى علي
القرني شرح في لقاء مع العربيه طبيعه
التجارب الطبيه المنشوده والمعنيه بتغيرات
الدماغ والجهاز العصبي واكيدان انها ستتم
بادوات جديده تستخدم لاول مره نتابع
سوف نقوم باجراء سته تجارب في الطب البشري
وهذا التجارب تعنى بدراسه التغيرات على
التي قد تصيب الدماغ الجهاز العصبي العظام
وكذلك النظر هذه الدراسات سبق وتم اجرائها
في بيئه الجاذبيه الصغرى ولكن الجديد انه
سوف يتم استخدام اجهزه جديده لاول مره في
الفضاء بشانها المساعده في تسريع النتائج
والتحاليل ان شاء الله وكذلك في الاستمطار
الصناعي وهذه تجربه فيزيائيه تعتبر كاول
مره تحدث كذلك في الفضاء وهي من شانها او
كفيله نتائج هذه التجربه بزياده ورفع
كفاءه الاستمطار الصناعي في الارض من 15%
الى اكثر من 50% ان شاء الله وسوف تساعدنا
باذن الله في الاسهام على مكافحه التصحر
ومشاريع السعوديه لرؤيه 20 30 مثل الرياض
الخضراء والشرق الاوسط الاخضر باذن الله
هذه المهمه تاتي ضمن احدى مبادرات الهيئه
السعوديه للفضاء ولكن انط
لقت بمكانه المملكه في مجال الفضاء وتطوير
قدراتها البشريه والصناعيه وستساعد هذه
المهمه في تاهيل كوادر السعوديه لخوض
رحلات فضائيه طويله وقصيره المدى بجانب
المشاركه في التجارب العلميه الابحاث
الدوليه والمهام المستقبليه المتعلقه
بالفضاء خاصه متى يعرف بطب الفضاء وهو
تخصص حديث يعنى بشكل اساسي بصحه رواد
الفضاء قبل السفر وتاكد من قدرتهم على
التكيف في الفضاء
طبعا طب الفضاء هو تخصص حديث يعنى بصحه
رواد الفضاء هو يهدف للتاكد من صحه رواد
الفضاء قبل السفر للفضاء والتاكد من
سلامتهم خلال تواجدهم في بيئه الفضاء
الشديده والتاكد من صحتهم وقدرتهم على
التكيف بعد العوده للارض طبعا الاثر الاول
لهذه التجربه انها من اوائل التجارب
الطبيه في الفضاء بدعم المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وهذا يؤكد دعم المملكه للابحاث
الطبيه في مجالي الطب والفضاء وهو تماشي
مع رؤيه 2030 وايضا الاثر الثاني هو
التاكد من سلامه رواد الفضاء ومساهمه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه في تقدم هذا
المجال
وبناء التدابير المضاده لحمايه رواد
الفضاء في المستقبل
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات